[Musique]
ici on a reproduit la silice de mandela
sur robben à l'aise dans ses dimensions
exactes
donc c'est tout petit il pouvait plus
marcher
[Musique]
s'il y a une image qui symbolise
l'endurance la persévérance de nelson
mandela
c'est bien celle ci mais cellule d'à
peine plus de deux mètres où mandela
n'avait pas toilettes seulement une
poubelle pour ses besoins et où il a
passé 18 de ses 27 années
d'emprisonnement
mandela l'homme qui a consacré sa vie à
un combat la lutte contre le régime de
l'apartheid en afrique du sud était un
sujet idéal pour un musée des droits de
la personne
l'apartheid est un régime qui a imposé
le pression raciale sur tous les aspects
de la vie en afrique du sud et si on
était blanc on vivait une vie très
privilégié la population noire en fait
était transformée au travers de ces lois
là en main d'oeuvre bon marché
un bon exemple ces pancartes qui
dirigeait les blancs et les noirs vers
des toilettes différente des hôpitaux
différents
des bancs publics différents
[Musique]
pour mettre fin à la ségrégation raciale
mandela s'engage en politique dès les
années 40
lorsque son parti le congrès national
africain est interdite en 1960 il se
radicalise
ici on va mandela qui est en
clandestinité
à ce moment là il passe dix sept mois à
voyager au travers de l'afrique jusqu'à
londres même avec un faux passeport
qu'on voit ici et cherche du support
pour le tram y seront des années très
dures mais aussi formatrice quoi
directeur du musée de l'apartheid
son musée basé à johannesbourg a
contribué à l'exposition de winnipeg
wallin job tu commandes inspectent en
prison manuel a réussi à gagner le
respect de ses gardiens qui étaient tous
lauryn hill a discuté avec eux ils
souhaitaient les comprends c'est là où
il a découvert l'importance de négocier
avec ses ennemis et quand il est sorti
de prison il ne voulait pas une guerre
civile
il voulait la réconciliation entre les
blancs et les noirs blancs l'exposition
ne se concentre pas seulement sur man
est là mais aussi sur tous ceux qui ont
lutté contre le régime de l'apartheid
y compris des québécois quand stephan
corriveau on avait fait une
manifestation dans les bureaux d'al qu'à
montréal
qui avaient investi dans l'afrique du
sud dans les années 80 des milliers
canadien milite activement pour que le
gouvernement de brian mulroney impose
des sanctions commerciales contre
l'afrique du sud
c'est une prise de conscience plus
nobles in on a réussi à contraindre le
gouvernement d'agir correctement mais en
imposant des sanctions
le canada s'oppose à ses alliés les
états unis l'angleterre qui eux appuient
régime de l'apartheid
le canada est un joueur tardive sur la
scène mais qui prend très vite le
leadership et c'est justement cette
politique anti apartheid qui va les
rendre fameux au niveau de la scène
internationale
l'exposition se termine sur ces images
de victoires avec la libération de
mandela en 90 avec tout son travail de
réconciliation pour éviter la guerre
civile mais aussi avec tout ce qu'il
reste à accomplir
les nouvelles générations via le
questionnement mai mais qu'est ce que
t'en changer l'apartheid a créé des
inégalités profondes difficiles à
éliminer mais selon lui le message de
réconciliation mandela demeure plus que
jamais d'actualité
[Musique]